you're looking at moscow where the
russian government has been cracking
down on protests against the war in
ukraine welcome back to cbs mornings
this footage shows one protest being
broken up earlier in the war
but anti-war demonstrations are now rare
as the punishment for telling the truth
has become far more severe to escape the
crackdown hundreds of thousands of
russians have left their country lilia
luciano shows us the painful struggle of
one russian family to get out
yulia her two children and the few
things she carries with her are now
tucked into small spaces at her sister
olga's home near san francisco when do
you start suspecting that you didn't
really have a future in russia
i think the
the strangest thing is
i could even now have a future in russia
building my career
raising my kids but i don't want to be
scared for them to be persecuted for
something in the largest country in the
world there is little space for dissent
protests against the invasion have met
harsh crackdowns news outlets are being
silenced and new laws threatened jail
time for spreading so-called
misinformation about the russian
military i'm actually very angry that i
had to go but what did it for me was
another of putin's speeches when he said
okay
when he mentioned
atomic weapons and things i was like
now i'm scared yulia her sister olga and
her brother yaakov are all u.s citizens
their parents fled the soviet union in
the 80s as political refugees but after
college yulia returned
russia was very exciting it was new
there was so much happening and it just
seemed very free cut 20 years later
i'm a refugee again
retracing the steps of her parents
i'm trying to fight the feeling of being
a failure
like my parents did so much to get us
out
and here i am again
yulia and her two children are dual
citizens that american passport makes
them the exception giving them an easier
way out but she left behind her 93 year
old grandmother who didn't have a visa
her brother jacob visiting moscow from
his home in massachusetts took over to
try to get her out but he soon realized
what he was up against
we talked to almost every u.s embassy in
europe seeking freedom or fleeing the
crushing consequences of sanctions many
russians are trying to escape but where
europe is opening doors to ukrainian
refugees
russians are finding a dead end it's
really tough for russia anaidah
siddiqian is an immigration lawyer in
los angeles helping russians file asylum
claims all the sanctions that western
car countries took against russia there
is basically no flights it's really hard
to get out of
right now out of options more russians
are heading to mexico where it's easier
to get a tourist visa they then make
their way to the u.s border where many
are now camping out along with
ukrainians and central american refugees
seeking asylum more than 7 000 russians
have entered the u.s through the
southern border this year that's almost
double the number from last year who
were the people fleeing most people that
i see are supporters of the opposition
bright individuals educated some people
are
members of lgbt community it's like
younger crowd in their 20s i think it's
going to be really bad for russia not
just in an economic sense but like in a
cultural sense but hope isn't out of the
question even for an elderly russian
grandma we're coming during a zoom call
yakov shared with us the news they were
all waiting for the embassy in iran
approved visas for my grandmother
and sister and brother-in-law
we got visas
and tickets
yakov was able to fast-track an
emergency visa appointment in armenia
because of his grandmother's medical
issues
and after a month and a half the family
finally welcomed their matriarch to the
u.s
mission accomplished
but one thing remains clear for them
they are the exception i have this like
guilt kind of complex about it the fact
that we were able to find connections
that helped us expedite it for people
who don't have that we're trying to get
out i mean it's near impossible
for cbs mornings lilia luciano san
francisco
as lilia says hope isn't out of the
question